foreign
of a former shopping mall which has been
converted into a 40 bedroom top-end
webcam business they're going to give me
a tour
for each of the room we have a different
design so you're not going to have two
rooms at the same in our studio I'm at
best studios in Romania's Capital
Bucharest this is the Rolls-Royce of the
webcam industry with Acres of Italian
marble floors Sumptuous furniture and
lots of young enthusiastic University
graduates on its books Maria bolegina is
the operations manager dressed in
expensive silk blouse hair cropped and
bleached blonde she's a former webcam
woman herself we are a studio we provide
models the space from where they can
stream online we provide them the
training and everything they need to be
a good model online she explains that
the girls are treated like stars given
tuition no oh sorry I'm just going to
pause it for a sec I'm not I'm not clear
because as I understand it Andrew
interesting got out of running webcam
girls years ago they found the drama
between the girls and uh the effort
required like the ROI to run the
business wasn't really worth it so from
what I understood from my conversations
with him they got out of the business
but the way that they're describing this
conversation is this uh unit this unit
on the sixth story of this old shopping
plaza with 40 rooms is still being run
by him is that correct no no so what
they're trying to say is they go into a
different webcam Studio which he's
claiming is the Rolls-Royce of webcam
Studios so this has no affiliation with
the tits and so that's important because
look how he's framing it oh it's amazing
you know they train the women it's a
very brilliant business model they give
the kids women training they provide a
platform it's Marble flaws and so on and
so forth so can you see how he's framing
this entire business as something which
is done in a in a brilliant manner now
compare that to the way he's framing the
way that Tates are doing the business
very differently because he doesn't know
if the women are in good condition when
it comes to tear and actually based on
the documents that we've released at the
moment there's been zero alligators that
the conditions were terrible so from
that one can surmises that the
conditions were good and yet his frame
of one is good and one is bad in terms
of your second point about the webcam
from the core documentary right it
doesn't seem like they're actually in
trouble for webcam it seems like they're
actually in trouble for only fans and
tick tock
okay
helped with makeup and clothes and that
paying punters around the world log into
their streams you have a free chat
section over every member or guest of
the site can see you and they have
access to you and then you have a
private session where the members they
have to pay to see you and talk to you
so you are not allowed to show nudity at
all then you have the premium side where
in free chat they allow you to do
whatever you want you can be naked you
can use sexual voice it depends on you
whatever you want to do the company
takes around 10 percent of the women's
earnings though it's standard for
Studios to take up to 50. Maria explains
this great care
another important point
he says it's standard practice for
Studios to take 50 percent
and
in the court documents it states that
the worst woman so the worst claim the
worst claim is in terms of the
proportion she receives is the woman
says I received 50 and Andrew received
25 so she is receiving double of what
Andrew tear is receiving
so that is important because this Rolls
Royce or standard practice what he calls
it's not the roles right but the
standard practice that he call what he
called standard practice is 50.
so how was that extortion why that's
important is an important element of
human trafficking is that you're
exploiting or as essentially modern day
slavery so the person people are working
on a slave contract so how can it be
that you're working on a slave contract
when you're receiving 50 of the revenue
whilst Andrew Taylor is receiving half
of that and he has to pay for the
whatever the normal business
expenditures
now now the critics watching this will
bark if I don't bring this up but
there's a video out there somewhere I
think of a private educational course
that he sold where he states that um he
would tell the girls that it would be 50
50 but he needs them to fill out a form
to withhold uh whatever it was 20 taxes
so they would get 30 but he would never
pay the taxes and throw the like the
form in the garbage how does that
um how do you think that that's going to
affect his case well I think that's an
important point you've made because what
it is is Festival that's a very old
video
so let's assume there's two
possibilities either he did do that or
he would just saying it as bravado and
what people don't understand is in terms
of the bravado aspect one has to
understand that where he's come from
he's come from basically Luton which is
and from a council estate which if you
were to
provide a comparison to the United
States is like a ghetto so when people
come from that kind of upbringing you
have you talk in this weird it's kind of
like gangster type way look I'm a G I'm
a Gangster I made a trillion you know
I'm giving that girl 30 but really
should be 50 so there's a possibility
that he was talking in that money but
let's so that's one possibility and one
could not be convicted on what you say
online unless you've there's
demonstrated evidence that you've done
that for example if I say I killed
Malcolm
but Malcolm's not dead I'm not going to
get convicted for killing him it doesn't
matter what I said online but if I said
I killed Malcolm and then Malcolm's
actually dead then you're like you know
what this sounds like a confession so
him saying it there has to actually be
evidence that he's done it so now
looking at it the evidence is suggesting
he didn't do it the evidence is saying
actually he received half so he received
25 and the women received 50 as opposed
to what that video is saying where he
receives 70 and the women receive 30
that's the first point the second point
that in even in that video he
contradicts himself a few times first he
says I take all the money so you can
sniff that I'll make him look bad in the
same video he says we get 50 50 and then
later in the video he says oh I give her
30 because of tax reasons so they're the
two points that I think are quite
important about that issue
okay
everybody's taken when it comes to
recruitment to make sure the women are
under no pressure or being exploited if
you feel comfortable she can leave any
time they don't have a contract here uh
to keep them collaborating with us she
can live anytime she want it's very
strange because if you go to any webcam
model in Romania she will never tell you
that she was feeling that
fear and that she was coerced to stay in
a studio never
the same can't be said for Sophie Tate X
from the UK she thought that she was
going to be his girlfriend she had no
idea what actually lay in store
he approached me on Facebook originally
completely out the blue it didn't ring
any bells but just right off the back
the way he spoke the way he made me feel
he was very charming and he made himself
seem very familiar he made me feel very
comfortable there were no red flags at
all in the beginning he just took an
interest in my day-to-day life what to
know what was into what made me happy
it was developing naturally
Sophie says that he then asked her to
join him in Romania she'd never met him
before but it felt right to Sophie in
that moment
I was at a stage of my life where
everything sort of felt a bit boring and
a bit dull and this idea of an adventure
and then lifestyle and this guy seemed
so into me and he's making me smile
every day and the idea just seemed
attractive to me
so Sophie came to Romania and she ended
up in Tate's weird meat factory home a
possible scene fine
so can you see again she's providing
consent she's saying look at this guy
who started a relationship I really
liked him and then I decided to move out
the presenter says oh suggested it
irrespective of who suggested this she's
completely been clear that it was her
autonomous decision to move to Romania
so is that now the case that if somebody
if two people are in love or they meet
each other from different cities and one
person moves and they don't like the
relationship you can then basically
claim human trafficking because again
that's how they're framing it so can you
see how when you're framing these ideas
the ramifications of it that's why I say
you may not like it you might not like
the things he's done you may not like
the entire industry that he's part of
but when you are basically highlighting
certain issues and framing in the mass
trafficking or framing them as rape you
better be well damn sure that whatever
principle you're using that they're very
well defined principles because guess
what they always go after people you
don't like first and then they then use
them principles to go after you
yeah this is
um you know let's let's Carry On Let's
carry on with this the Stars he was
quite Charming but then something
strange happened
the first couple of days of being with
him he was as I expect him to be and
then I can't remember how long I was
there for the first time I think it was
four or five days it was quite a long
time considering it was the first time
we'd met but it just disappeared in the
middle of the night he was in bed next
to me and I heard him get up and I
thought he's just gone to the bathroom
and he just didn't come back
Sophie was in his house alone for days
the man she thought was her boyfriend
had vanished it was odd and in hindsight
a little disturbing but she had no idea
that this was his Mo that he targeted
women that he hoped would work in his
expanding webcam Empire treating them
like property
devised his own
so two pounds first thing is he
disappears for five days
you move to a different country if that
doesn't drink alarm Bells what does like
if you've got an issue there you could
have left why didn't you leave first
point second point is this she says that
he treats women as property she doesn't
provide the Dare or evidence for this
but one can only surmise that she's
referring to the interview with Pierce
Morgan
I assume if she's referring to that
interview with Pierce Morgan he's quite
clear that what he means by that is not
property in terms of an
asset but what he means is in a
traditional family whether it comes to
the Judo Christian or Muslim so the
abrahamic religions there's this idea
that when you get married there's one
pays a dowry to the family and there's a
contract that occurs and then the woman
is then becomes part of the Man's family
so he explains that quite well and
explains his reasoning for it even if
you may disagree
but what I will say is this the reason
why the West finder harder to believe is
because in the west they actually
consider men the property of women
because if you look at it and I can just
give the United Kingdom's example
in the United Kingdom men are the
property of women because as soon as you
get married to a woman it's you're
basically signing a deal to say there's
a one-way monogamous relationship where
a man isn't allowed to cheat if he does
she will divorce him and she will take
half of everything he's got on the other
hand a woman doesn't sign the same
agreement because
she can be polygamous she can cheat on
him and there's no ramifications because
if she does
what what will happen the man then has a
decision to make either he accepts it
and allows a polygamous relationship to
continue and all he says this is
unacceptable if he says it's
unacceptable he divorces her she takes
half of everything he's got so in the
west man is the property of war and
hence why they don't like our statement
yeah that's a fair statement uh we got a
question here were the Tate still doing
webcam work in 2022 I don't know if you
caught it earlier but I asked them about
it during a podcast and my understanding
was they got out of the business years
ago I don't know if you've heard
anything different
um yeah so according to the documents
they weren't doing webcam it's actually
on uh only fans and
um
okay
all right let's carry on here use this
guide for how to recruit women into
webcaming which he shared on something
called Pick Up Artist tools.com not a
site I frequent
in it Tate explains the secrets of how
we target
sorry let me just pause that for a
second because I because I looked up
Pick Up Artist tools.com it's an
affiliate site that that links to a lot
of different pickup artists courses and
material I don't believe that the Tates
put their material there I believe they
have an affiliate code that's listed
somewhere and whoever runs the site
posts the link to all these offers that
they have out there so I think they
frame that unfairly yeah that's that was
my understanding as well
it's young sometimes vulnerable women
listen to this I don't mention webcam
until after I've had sex with a girl if
you're on dates and you're trying to
mention it and [__] it just doesn't work
it puts them off I'd never do that
that's disgusting I'm not a [__] it's
just not gonna work
listen to what Sophie says happened when
she finally flew into Romania there was
no mention of webcaming when they talked
on Facebook she thought that this was
about romance I didn't really think of
you know what could this really be about
and it didn't really cross my mind so
there was some naivety there I guess
from my part and here's Tate again
teaching how to exert pressure on
potential recruits then you start
mentioning things like yeah but you know
you're always busy you're always at work
you can come work for me a couple of
times he'd said to me oh you should do
it you'd make a fortune but you don't
have to you know you don't want to you
don't have to do it please you can do
nothing
so two points the first thing is this is
again people's incorrect understanding
of how it works they are trying to make
it look like that this love of that boy
method or whatever you call it is
actually illegal in itself but it's not
because this is a normal mechanism by
which people start relationships you
know you provide you know you
demonstrate the best part of you the
woman demonstrates the best part of that
and then you just have to go in a
relationship it's only when you then
apply this and it meets the standards of
human trafficking like I said previously
slavery not being able to have free
movement and so on and so forth then and
you meet all them conditions does that
apply and then you apply to human
trafficking so it's people trying to
incorrectly applying so people I've seen
it online where they're automatically
like guess what this looks like lover
boy he's guilty no that's just um one
aspect to use to then prove the greater
aspect which is human trafficking and
they fail to do that and the second
point is this she says
he says to her you don't have to do it
if I don't if you don't wanna
that sounds like consent
yeah they always have the option to
leave and they were getting paid
so how are they held against their will
that's that's a confusing part right
yeah
make enough money as I said you cannot
try and approach girls to do webcam so
you don't want girls in for money you
want girl who's in it to be with you but
it was always reminding me that the
option was there and that kind of
progressed into well if you love me you
would do it if you care about me you
would do it because you know this is my
business and we can build something
together and make all this money and we
can buy property and we can invest and
we can build this this thing together
now Tate talks about closing the deal
so just a quick one we'll build it
together we'll make money together we'll
buy properties together
that is a business deal a business
transaction where two family members
have gone are part of a business
family members in terms of because they
have a relationship in this regard so
again that does not that demonstrates
that it doesn't meet the standards of
human trafficking once again
he says you take the woman to a Smart
restaurant where a previously recruited
webcomer will come along and help with
the coercion it starts with alcohol
martinis martinis martinis Bank
threesome slam them both bottom [__]
knows this girl's like okay well I'll
try it put both girls on camera together
the first day give me a bottle of vodka
the guys will send loads of money to get
the girls drunk I think over time just
chipping away at me eventually led me to
think yeah maybe he's right
so can you see how he's they've played
that clip to make Andrew Taylor sound
bad which obviously doesn't sound great
but the woman in in the women's story
there's no woman who talks to her
there's no bottom B who comes and talks
to her and tries to convince her so
again you see how they playing audios
but then her story doesn't match those
audios
yeah they don't line up
maybe I should be doing it and I guess
it depends on the individual girl the
tactics he uses depends on the situation
the road he will go down to get them to
doing it that's how you recruit girls
do not recruit girls any other way
more than a thousand miles away from
Bucharest in my car in that Motorway
service station car park Sophie had a
lot of time to reflect on those years
with Andrew Tate
she done modeling and pole dancing
before working for Tate so it was an
industry that she'd been on the fringes
of but she'd been pulled in by takes
promise of romance and had never planned
to end up in the situation she found
herself pause please it's all
so from my information she was in the
business but let's just go with what she
said so she was a pole dancer so and she
says is the industry that she was on the
fringes of my argument is actually if
you're in a strip club and you're a pole
dancer you are in the sex industry and
you're in it from a more physical
interaction when it comes to men as
opposed to being behind the camera
uh we got a question here or sorry
saying the woman that that woman was
deluded in her own fantasy of her
relationship and decided to take revenge
when she realized Her Fantasy was
nothing in reality and she couldn't face
her delusions victim mindset
um look you know women always reserve
the right to change their mind at any
given time and if you two become popular
and famous and say controversial things
in ways that aren't warm and fuzzy and
covered in rainbows and butterflies you
two could be you know in Andrew Tate's
type of scenario so this this is
something that men need to pay attention
to you know for being honest here
yeah you need to be safe manipulation
and there's an ulterior motive to
everything he does it's difficult for
people to understand that having felt
how manipulative he is or other men can
be unless you've had an experience of
that
what she's described to Georgia appears
to be a form of psychological coercion
which in the UK is called grooming and
in Romania has a different name though
it's just as serious what you're talking
about is something that we call the
Romeo trafficker or the lover boy
technique Iona Bauer is from Romanian
NGO e liberare that helps women who've
been trafficked victims will not
necessarily self-identify as victims
they're always going to find
explanations of why that is happening
however you always have to follow the
money who is profiting from there um if
the trafficker actually taking money
that's being generated by that
particular person we tend to think of
human trafficking as forcing people
across borders and keeping them against
their will but psychological coercion is
also a form of this dirty business human
trafficking is actually hidden in plain
sight the change that we maybe imagine
they're not always visible a lot of
times they're psychological it might be
the fact that they're so ashamed
somebody's going to find out what has
happen to them then they're literally
stuck
I went back to prepare the neighborhood
where Tate's house is because we'd had a
tip-off nearby in a row so I did talk
about the Loverboy method but and I've
already demonstrated why that's flawed
but look again another example so they
sent a psychological coercion
and then what what do they mean by that
how do how do you know something a
psychological conversion a coercion
because in reality when you look at the
information that's been presented it's
merely a guy and a girl who liked each
other the girl came over to Romania and
there was some kind of relationship
there was a possibility of webcam or she
did do it for a short period of Time how
was that coercion like that it just does
not meet the requirements and why that's
a concern once again is I don't want I
keep talking about it but look we do
live in a world a man-hating world where
men's problems are completely ignored
and so now you're having a scenario
where a man can be taken out for the
minimalist reason because you can
literally just say he's psychologically
manipulated me and you can basically
accuse him of anything and
just to demonstrate that men hatred is
so high is because look even this issue
rape we know data data completely shows
that actually it's men who are raped
more than women in the United States and
yet no one will ever tell you that men
go through significant issues that that
women don't go through but no one ever
highlights it because we live in a world
where nobody cares about men and so this
is another way of degrading aggregating
men
I know I know men that have been raped
and nobody listens nobody cares it's wow
you know how do you rape a man I'll tell
you the story one day offline when we're
not running the camera but women have
done it I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out